i'm grandmaster daniel nardiski we're
watching gary kasparov face off against
lenier dominguez from the 2017 saint
louis rapid and blitz and we have e4 e5
will this be a rue lopez
gary has shown an affinity for the rue
lopez in the blitz tournament since his
retirement yes he plays it and lanier
responding with a berlin and gary going
knight c3 transitioning the game into
the four knights knight d4 one of the
most reputable systems
uh very ambitious now gary could take on
d4 he could take on e5 or he can ignore
by castling or moving his bishop gary
taking the first think of the game
bishop a4 and bishop c4 i think are the
modern lines yep bishop a4
and now dominguez responded with bishop
c5 gary immediately capturing the pawn
on a5 so this is a pawn sacrifice
now most likely it's temporary as far as
i remember generally black ends up
winning the pawn on e4 back
uh after quick development so i think
lenier is going to castle here and
oftentimes gary often times white brings
the knight back to d3 in these kinds of
situations to hit the bishop on c5 and
pave the way for e5
dominguez taking taking his time
and he castles gary immediately going
knight d3 dominguez bishop b6 and
there's there's e5 gary pushing that
pawn forcing lanier's knight back to e8
and right now gary is up upon as he puts
his knight on d5 the only issue with
white's position is that gary will have
a hard time developing the dark squared
bishop because it's currently being
blocked
by the knight on d3
so he's going after dominguez's bishop
on b6 he's up upon i really like gary's
position out of the opening year and now
dominguez
taking a bit of a longer think he goes
c6 chasing the knight on
on d5 and gary doesn't take the bishop
on b6 that's a bit surprising he drops
the knight back to e3 so maybe he just
wanted to centralize the night he never
wanted to take that bishop lenier going
d5 expanding in the center now gary
could take on croissant but in that
resulting position the lack of
development on the queen side could
potentially hurt white so i think it's
in gary's best interest to keep the
position closed and he does he castles
he maintains the pawn on e5
how is lanyard going to continue his
initiative will he play f6 trying to
open up the f file for his pieces
let's see yep he plays f6 offering a
trade gary chases the knight away from
d4
dominguez moves it to f5
now gary could trade knights but that
would enable black's light square bishop
to develop a tempo and hit that
incredibly vulnerable knight on d3 which
currently doesn't have any pawns
defending it so my guess is gary's gonna
keep the tension and improve his
position
but he needs to get that knight out of
d3 in order to develop the bishop
alternatively he can fianchetto but if
he plays pawn to b3 here then that
bishop on a4 could end up getting
trapped with a timely b7 b5 in fact i
think that loses the bishop after bishop
takes c3 b5 and so gary plays bishop c2
very logical move he gets the bishop out
of a4 now i think he can fianchetto his
other bishop you can go b3 and then
either bishop b2 or bishop a3 to attack
lenio's rook on f8 i still like gary's
position i think the onus right now is
on dominguez to prove his compensation
maybe he'll do the same and go bishop c7
trying to force the trade of of e5 takes
f6
or maybe he'll develop his light square
bishop plan you're taking
a pretty long thing here you can see
gary with his hands over his head he is
deep in thought in a position i like my
position but you know i have to find
different ways you know to develop the
bishop on c1 but you know eats it it's
very successful opening against
dominguez lanier seems a little bit
frustrated he goes queen e7 and he
attacks the pawn on e5 so this is a
similar move to bishop c7
now will gary take on f6 that
unfortunately allows the knight on e8
back into the game that's exactly what
dominguez wants
but
how do you support the pawn on e5 can
you go f4 f4 is a pretty risky move as
well because then that allows that
basically self pins the knight on e3 and
creates weaknesses gary's shaking his
head a little bit
seems to be a little bit frustrated here
it is hard to untangle this is a big
decision does he take on f6 does he go
f4
or does he give the pawn up on e5 i
don't think he's gonna do that
taking a pretty long think here
and f4 does look pretty logical and
tempting that knight on e3 is pretty
well protected by the pawn on d2 so i
wouldn't be too worried about the pin
uh imposed by the bishop on b6 should
gary play f4
and the other advantage of the move four
is that it keeps the knight on e8 out of
the game because the pawn on e5 is
what's restricting that knight on e8 not
allowing it to join the game via f6 a
long thing for gary who's getting
himself in a fair bit of time pressure
here he's been thinking for right about
a minute
and let's see what he comes up with
doesn't show any signs of making a move
just yet this has to be good news for
linear because the position remains
incredibly complicated this is going to
be so hard to handle in time and there
it is here going for f4 a gutsy decision
and now he's got to be careful about his
king safety
but this forces lanier to continue
trying to prove compensation for the
pawn now we could have a trade on e3 and
then a trade on e5 that's one possible
continuation but maybe lanyard decides
to keep the tension but if he does that
how does he continue improving his
position does he take on e5 does he get
his light squirt bishop out to e6 that
just seems a little bit flimsy and now
gary i think is ready to play b3 and
then maybe a4 and bishop a3 so
white has a pretty clear plan of
improving his position
black on the other hand
has a bit of a harder time improving his
linear a little bit disconcerted here he
was about to make a move let's see if he
takes one of white's pieces either on e3
or on e5 that would be my guess
that just seems like the most logical
way to continue but linear there we go
yep he takes knight takes e3
pawn takes e3 and bishop out to f5 so he
doesn't take the pawn on e5 instead he
develops his light square bishop and now
he's threatening potentially to take the
knight on d3 and then take the pawn on
e5
and that'll end up winning the pawn back
gary with a very important decision here
will he continue his plan of b3a4 bishop
a3 or will he take on f6 now he goes to
a4 first so this is a multi-purpose move
he wants to play a5 and chase away
black's bishop what a move and he also
is preparing to play pawn b3 and then
bishop a3 now lennar could take the
knight on d3 and take the pawn on e5 but
that comes with certain risks as well
white's queen could jump out to h5 and
threaten checkmate bishop c7 by lanier
putting more pressure on e5 this might
be high time for gary to take on f6 but
that lets the knight back into the game
and that knight now has access to that
really really weak e4 square which white
is weakened with a move four gary
instead going b3 keeping the tension and
preparing bishop a3 what an interesting
move f takes e5 is probably going to
happen and gary wants to respond to that
with bishop a3
when lenier will have to block that pin
with his bishop and potentially
relinquish his control over the e5 pawn
so gary might actually be keeping his
extra pawn here in a really interesting
roundabout way lanier
about to make a move f takes c5 and
bishop a3 instantly by gary bishop b6
have a trade and gary's still with an
extra pawn after knight takes e5 he's
doing pretty well here ooh but lenier
has an idea takes takes and what about
knight f7 here what a move by lanier now
that can test the knight on e5
and if you take on f7 black will take on
e3 with check first and then recapture
the knight on f7 and then dominguez will
have no problems at all gary could drop
his knight back to g4 where it defends
e3 but then pawn h5 forces the knight
off prize its fingers off the ledge
and it looks like lenier has managed to
win the pawn back what a sequence seeing
knight f7 that wasn't easy at all and
that gets gary into another think
i think for gary it's a decision between
different ways of losing the pawn back
and then material will be equal white
has a bunch of weak pawns the pawn on f4
the pawn on c3 all of white's queen side
pawns are pretty flimsy black's pawn
structure on the other hand is really
really healthy so i think the position
is approximately equal but gary's time
situation is quite concerning as he
takes another long think here
tries to figure out which alternative is
better does he want to keep the knights
on the board and go knight g4 or knight
d3 or does he want to train on f7 he can
even force a rook end game he can take
on f7 and then after queen takes e3
check he can go queen f2 and force the
trade of queens that is probably the
fastest way toward a draw but gary
probably feeling a little bit more
ambitious after all he was up a pawn out
of the opening i don't think he wants to
acquiesce to a draw this early but it
might be time to do that that might be
the wise decision as he continues to
contemplate his next move
he's down to close to a minute what is
gary going to do
as he leans in and back out vintage
moves he seems frustrated he still
hasn't made a move
he has to start playing fast here
and knight g4 is what he decides on
immediately here goes h5 knight back to
f2 miner takes the pawn back on e3 now i
think black is basically you know in
pretty good shape here white's now got a
bunch of weak pawns the queen on e3
though could end up being vulnerable
first of all gary has to defend upon an
f4 and he does with the move g3 now will
lanier bring his rook into the game with
rook 8 to e8 that seems incredibly
logical and that also prevents rook 81
because black will just take on e1 and
get two rooks for the queen and with
white's king being as vulnerable as it
is two rooks for a queen seems to be in
black's favor here so rook ae8 seems
really reasonable for linear gary
shaking his head
he had a good position out of the
opening but wasn't able to cling to his
extra pawn
let's see what lanyard decides on here
he is taking a pretty significant think
and it is rook a to e8 now gary needs to
find a way to get active his knight is
pinned his queen is tied up queen g6
very interesting move by gary he hits
the pawn on h5 he abandons his queen
side so lanier can start mopping up
those pawns he can play queen takes c3
here and then even queen takes b3 is on
the card cards but then he'll have to
give up the h5 pawn and black will have
some worries with his own king safety i
like that practical chance i think queen
g6 very very good practical move and it
poses another decision in front of black
lanyard taking his own time trying to
figure out what to do he can also push
the pawn down to h4 and try to give it
up on his own terms glances over the
clock
and i other than taking the pawn on c3
and going h4 i don't see too many other
options i mean black can defend it with
queen f3 but that walks right into
a potential discovered attack because of
the rook on f1 so queen f3 queen e2 both
of those moves look a little bit flimsy
but maybe lanyard doesn't want to part
ways with that h pawn because every pawn
that disappears on the king side
is bad news for blacks and he does go
for queen f3 interesting decision there
and now his queen very very precarious
we're going to see a major acceleration
of players both players now low on time
will gary defend the pawn no he'll go
rook 81 he'll contest the e file he
continues to offer that c3 pawn up but
if lanier takes it once again he'll have
to give up his age pawn
and he was about to get a hold of his
rook but now he hesitates
will linear trade on e1 yes he does he
gives up the e file and he goes knight
to h6 so he still doesn't take the c3
bomb but that isn't that is a bit of an
odd choice i thought lanier had to take
the pawn on c from now gary has control
of the evil he can even infiltrate with
rookie seven but then lanier is planning
knight f5 defending g7 and hitting the
rooks pushing his chair in his gary you
can see the anxiety queen back to d3
offering a queen trade that's a very
prudent decision when you're forced to
trade queens now why does white's in
great shape in the same game he's got
control of the e file
and he goes a5 freezing black queen side
pawns now the knight can jump into c5
when you're getting his king and knight
e5 check you can't go up to f6 he has to
go back this is deteriorating four
lanier b4 expanding on the queen side
rookie gate king f2 bringing the king up
how does lanyard untangle he goes a6 but
now look at that b7 pawn that's an
incredibly weak pawn and gary goes for a
97 he wants to get his knight to c5 and
ty black down we have a trade of brooks
this is probably still closer to a draw
than to anything else but gary
definitely in the driver's seat he's got
a pawn majority on the king side that he
can exploit right about now h3 g4 and he
can keep expanding as he first
uh yep he goes h3 he's going to bring
his king into f3 as well g4 first
expanding on the king side gary only one
who can win this game right now he's in
phenomenal shape lanyard keeps looking
over at the cloud g5 and king f3 pushing
the king up preparing to get a pass pawn
lanyard goes king g6 black basically can
do nothing but how does gary improve his
position will he go f5 he does he
establishes a protected pat's pawn on f5
now he's getting his kingdom in the
center knight t14 before lanier has to
go back to d6 knight b7 pushing black's
king back now 99 c5 gary repeating once
how does he make progress back to d3 he
goes lanier has to move his own king
back and forth king e3
so far gary not seeming to find a way to
make progress king up six black
teetering on the brink king before an
ip5 check he has to go back to d3 again
is this going to be a draw by repetition
gary is trying to force zugswang knight
c4 i think he has to go back to d7 i
think he has to go back to d7 and push
black king off of f6 but gary not seeing
it yet
and he has to be very careful about
three-time repetition knight e6 he's
paving the way for his king to go to c5
i think he wants his king to tackle
those queenside pawns this is a really
really hard thing to defend against in
time brusher
and now knight d8 now lanier has to go
back to d6 and king c5 here comes gary's
king i think this is winning for white
knight d4 check king b6 and black will
lose all of his pawns knight takes c3
linear taking one pawn but gary's gonna
take the pawn on a6 i think this is
winning for white the knight is going to
drop back to c5 and prevent the progress
of the d-pawn lanyard going after the
b-pawn but gary he's left with the most
valuable pass pawn in the position he
has the past a pawn and he has contained
all of the pawns he sacrifices his
knight and here comes the a pawn and i
don't think lanier can stop it i don't
think lanier can stop the pawn he cannot
white is going to promote and he resigns
what a display by gary kasparov he keeps
his golden time pressure an amazing game
and if you want to see more videos like
this make sure to click on the link uh
to the playlist that's popping up on
your screen i'm jim daniel nerditsky
hope you enjoyed this incredible game
between gary kasparov and leonardo
dominguez thank you for watching
[Music]